TADAAA ! yes.
Et bien bonjour à vous, bonjour à toi Clément qui monte cette vidéo,
J'espère que tout le monde va bien (rire)
Aujourd'hui je suis très content parce que je fais une vidéo où je vais parler
d'un... d'une nouvelle passion que j'ai découvert vous savez je me découvre des passions tous les mois
mais y'a plein de trucs qui me fascine
c'est cool d'être fasciné par plein de choses.
Et là ce qui me fascine c'est les vidéos de l'INA
Vous connaissez sûrement il y en a certaines qui ont tourné sur Facebook, énormément!
Qu'est-ce que l'INA ? C'est l'institut national de l'audiovisuel qui est chargée entre autre d'archiver les émissions radios les émissions télé
et c'est incroyable je sais pas il y a peut-être que moi qui ai ce kiff mais je trouve ça fou de voir des gens qui ont
notre âge mais 50 ans ou 60 ans avant nous.
C'est impressionnant.
La vidéo la plus connue de l'ina c'est une série d'interviews auprès des jeunes où on leur demandait en 62,
comment selon eux allait être l'an 2000.
Je vous met le lien en description si vous voulez aller la voir mais elle a tellement tourné sur Facebook que on va pas checker ça ensemble aujourd'hui.
Aujourd'hui, on a vraiment juste regarder les trucs par exemple qui concerne je ne sais pas à l'école la technologie comment pensaient les jeunes comment
pensaient nos parents quand ils avaient notre âge on sait les parents on sait comment vous pensiez parce qu'il y a des preuves sur l'ina.
Vous n'avez pas pensé à supprimer ces archives...
Regardons ça ensemble j'ai fait une petite sélection qui parle de différents trucs je sais pas trop si elles ont tourné sur Facebook celles-ci.
Mais en tout cas j'ai envie de vous en parler parce qu'il pas mal de choses à dire alors c'est parti
Je vous contextualise on est en 65 et un journaliste va interviewer deux jeunes pour leur demander ce qu'ils pensent de la France
Comment ils sont dans leur vie, est-ce qu'ils sont bien, est-ce qu'ils sont malheureux, qu'est-ce qui va pas dans le pays etc.
Et c'est incroyable, alors attention ces deux jeunes ne représentent pas tous les jeunes de l'époque mais leur témoignage est incroyable.
Je ne sais pas de quoi il parle pour le moment, je ne comprends pas pour le moment.
Leur style, s'il vous plaît, je veux que ceci reviennent à la mode !
S'il vous plaît
Moi c'est trop tard pour moi, mais ceux qui ont des veuch allez-y, laissez vous poussez les veuch c'est incroyable
Mais tu critiques aussi là,
actuellement t'es en train de chier sur tout le monde.
C'est génial il se plaint que les gens critiquent tout mais il lui même là est en train de tout critiquer
Oh nan le pauvre, oh nan...
Le pauvre tout s'explique, il en a marre du monde parce que tout le monde se moque de sa chevelure mais
Rassures-toi 45 ans plus tard ta coupe est devenue archi à la mode regardes t'étais juste visionnaire.
Et comme tous les visionnaires les gens t'ont critiqué bien joué à toi
Qu'est-ce qu'il...  vous êtes des hippies
Vous êtes des quoi j'arrive pas comprendre ce qu'il dit vous êtes des bicmic
VOUS ETES DES BEATNIKS !!
Je sais pas ce que c'est mais il parle d'un mouvement
anti confort etc un peu anti système mais j'arrive pas à trouver le nom.
Clément si tu as le nom marques le là, moi je l'ai pas
je n'ai pas la culture qu'il faut, c'est horrible
(rire)
Excuses-nous pardon
Monsieur il lui faut sa villa
sinon il ne part pas en vacances c'est hors de question
J'ai jamais vu un mec dire je pense à ma gueule et uniquement à ma gueule aussi...
librement, il s'en bat les couilles.
Reminder reminder
Je trouve les gens, par leur esprit, ils critiquent tout
Ils sont révoltés ces jeunes
(rire)
Il est génial, mais donnez la médaille de l'honnêteté à ce mec "j'aime l'argent je veux mon steak ma villa près de la plage je m'en bats les couilles"
ah, cette franchise ça c'est un truc à changer cette franchise là elle est incroyable
Vous avez vu ? C'est intéressant, pour lui la notion de travail c'est quelque chose qui ne plaît pas
Même encore aujourd'hui il y a encore un peu cette vision genre le travail c'est forcément quelque chose qui ne plaît pas
Mais on peut avoir un travail qui nous plaît
A l'époque j'ai l'impression que c'était vraiment beaucoup plus inconcevable quoi
De faire de son, de sa passion son travail et c'est hyper intéressant je trouve ce qu'ils disent.
Ces deux jeunes qui bossent et tout
Il y en a un qui parle même de faire Sciences Po une grande école et tout mais ils sont très:
"fuck le système" et cette même personne là qui à l'époque chier sur le système et le monde, aujourd'hui 50 ans après il te dit : "Moi de
mon époque on sortait les doigts du cul, on n'était pas comme ça, on acceptait les choses comme elles étaient"
et ben non on voit bien que c'est faux
si ton papa te dit qu'à son époque lui l'était pas comme toi, il acceptait son destin et tout... Mais montres lui ça !
et si c'est ton père dans la vidéo c'est encore mieux bon autre sujet intéressant c'est l'école dans l'émission qui suit on passe en
84 et ils vont aller interviewer des élèves et le sujet est centré sur la triche donc on va découvrir à l'époque comment les gens trichaient
ne trichez pas en cours, c'est pas du tout le message que je veux véhiculer
"une nouvelle manière de
frauder, inventée par un candidat au baccalauréat d'Orléans" non "pas question pour lui d'employer les vieux trucs du genre
antisèches dissimulées sur les poignées de chemise ou encore formules
inscrites dans le creux de la main" Comment a-t-il fait ? Dans les années 80 qu'est ce qu'il a fait ? c'est autant pas si vite possible
Ok vas-y
le mec il a un truc de la taille d'un stabilo dans l'oreille mon gars d'où il espérait ne pas se faire griller le
gars il est comme ça :
et en plus il fait ça ok attends attends pas si vite la production agricole dis moi combien combien excusez moi M ferdinand vous
trichez - non pas du tout je réfléchis simplement à haute voix - bon d'accord alors.  Mais enfin évidemment mais tu te fais griller
bon maintenant avec les téléphones portables et tout, ça peut peut-être moins vous étonner mais à l'époque c'était fou qu'un candidat ait triché
en utilisant une sorte de radio genre -le petit malin était un cibiste fervent il disposait d'un émetteur récepteur
à peu près gros comme ceux ci ,de deux petits écouteurs dissimulés dans une chevelure évidemment beaucoup plus abondante que la mienne
aaaah , c'est ça, la chevelure abondante, la chevelure abondante l'a sauvé - sa petite amie complaisante disposait de tous les ouvrages nécessaires
- complaisante [rire de moquerie] - pour faire face à n'importe quelle épreuve d'histoire géo du bac B, la triche était presque parfaite
presque seulement . - pourquoi il s'est fait griller qu'est ce qui s'est passé ?
- n'importe quel cibiste de passage dans les environs pouvait entendre lui aussi le dialogue et c'est ce qui s'est produit
La suite ! On est en 86 et l'émission parle toujours de l'approche du baccalauréat et donc de la triche. "Anne Rongère ce livre
un exercice que la morale réprouve elle va nous dévoiler
quelques recettes de triche oui vous avez bien entendu, de triche des recettes tirées d'un manuel impertinent
rédigé par un jeune nantais qui n'a pas froid aux yeux"
(rires) Y a un mec de Nantes qu'à rédigé un manuel avec plein de méthodes de triche, mets cet effort dans tes révisions mais pas dans le
but de corrompre les gens. "Désir Audric 20 ans
c'est parce qu'ils voulaient consacrer plus de temps au
tennis qu'il a mis au point sa méthode en 20 leçons pour tricher aux examens" Déjà on dirait qu'il a 30 ans
il ya peut-être une raison au fait que y passe son temps à tricher. "Avec ses petits camarades de classe,
il a sélectionné pour nous ces quelques conseils que la morale réprouve" Dis nous Désir Audric "Le reste se passe de commentaires" ahh
le stylo farci (rires)
les noms qu'ils donnent aux techniques de triche elles sont incroyables
oui ok jusque là tout le monde connaît tout ça le sac à malices
On dirait un objet dans Harry Potter c'est quoi le sac à malices ?
ah d'accord tu sors juste tes cours quoi et tu les caches dans ta copie. Non mais mec, ta copie elle passe de ça d'épaisseur
à ça, ne me dites pas que c'est pas grillé ok là il y a
Désir Audric notre dieu à tous qui nous dévoile une technique et regardez juste son
investissement personnel dans l'élaboration de techniques de triche. C'est incroyable. "Vous prenez une gratte à laquelle vous accrochez un élastique par l'intermédiaire d'une épingle à nourrice.
L'enfilez le long du bras, jusqu'en haut de l'épaule."
En vrai Désir Audric il aurait dû juste finir ingénieur et ça a mal tourné et il est devenu ingénieur dans l'élaboration de techniques de triche
ça c'est vraiment ça s'est joué à ça et maintenant
l'interview légendaire de Désir Audric. Ses arguments sont *smack* "Je triche pour
en fait parce que j'aime bien faire autre chose que travailler mes examens quand je vois arriver les sujets" Premier argument pas mal "On a
montré les sujets complètement stupides où il suffit juste de recracher le cours
à ce moment-là bon bah qu'est ce que je fais moi je veux pas passer cinq ou six heures à travailler ça ce que je
fais c'est que j'ai des cours que j'amène directement alors que la personne qui a qui a travaillé pour préparer l'examen
intellectuellement on retire absolument rien" Ah, cette phrase de rageux je disais exactement
pareil parce que j'étais un rageux comme lui et moi je vais pas à l'école pour apprendre
bêtement un truc par coeur et le réciter sur une copie
oui mais lui c'est ça l'école c'est la même chose pour tout le monde si d'autres en sont capables
tu peux en être aussi en fait il n'y a pas de... Non non non non non je vais plutôt m'investir dans la triche.
J'ai de l'avenir. "Qu'est-ce que vous conseilleriez à un jeune qui débute
bah on sait ce que tu vas dire Audric : "De travailler, de pas tout de suite tomber dans la triche", t'es bienveillant on sait bien
"Pour un jeune qui débute, je lui conseillerais de bosser" (rires)
Jounaliste : "Pourquoi ? "
"Non, non en fait c'est un gag. Je lui conseillerais de démarrer avec des méthodes très simples et très sûr."
Ok Audric est un psychopathe. Avez-vous déjà vu quelqu'un faire un rire si sincère pour redevenir sérieux en moins d'une demi seconde
J'ai tellement cru qu'il était sérieux la première fois que je l'ai vu, quand il a dit : "Non non c'est un gag." ça m'a mis sur
le cul. Bah peut-être que vous venez de vivre ça vous chez vous c'est traumatisant n'est ce pas ? "Je dirais qu'il y a une bonne partie des gens
qui
ont travaillé durant leur scolarité parce qu'ils n'arrivaient pas à pomper et généralement quand on travaille c'est qu'on sait pas pomper." Ce n'est pas du
tout parce que peut-être qu'on a envie de travailler et
d'accepter le système est de se dire : " Ah, c'est pas mal en fait. J'apprends des trucs ça, ma culture générale
elle upgrade et tout, c'est cool ! Non !
Si vous travaillez, c'est que vous ne savez pas pomper. C'est Audric qui l'a dit. Bon voilà, ça m'avait fait rire de voir ça, de
voir qu'à l'époque déjà la triche c'était très d'actualité, et que les gens ils mettaient tout leur cœur !
C'est fou ! Après la triche, parlons d'un truc un peu plus cool.
L'arrivée des inventions technologiques. Quand les médias commençaient à parler d'une technologie qui faisait un peu entendre parler d'elle.
Mais on savait pas trop ce que ça allait donner. On savait pas trop si ça allait impacter le monde ou pas et ça l'a impacté.
Et du coup, quand on les revoit présenter ça à l'époque sans savoir ce qui va se passer derrière c'est très
intéressant. On commence tout de suite avec les médias qui parlent des jeux vidéos. "Un nouveau venu cette année qui marche très fort, le jeu vidéo." PPDA
C'est fou présenter le jeu vidéo comme un nouveau venu ça me paraît tellement...
incroyable,
comme tout est allé si vite. "Petit frère du flipper et autres machines à sous qui ne se rencontraient guère que dans les cafés,
les jeux vidéos font leur entrée dans les salles de séjour."
Yes ! Grâce à lui, j'ai fait de ma passion, mon métier.
"Dans quelques années voire 2 ans, nous pourrons jouer contre la machine et nous pourrons utiliser le petit ordinateur de ménage,
pour faire sa comptabilité personnelle, voire organiser ses vacances."
Voire... Tout faire !
Ah, c'est fou. S'il savait c'est dingue. Il parle juste de faire sa petite comptabilité mais mec, maintenant on fait tout avec notre pc on organise
toutes nos journées.
On parle avec les autres. On... ça fait tellement tout. ça fait tellement plus que ce qu'ils imaginaient que ça ferait à ce moment là c'est
ça que je trouve incroyable. Enfin dernière innovation dont ils vont parler, c'est l'arrivée du walkman. Les premiers baladeurs portables pour écouter ta musique dans
la rue etc et vous allez voir c'était vraiment une énorme nouveauté c'est vraiment un
bouleversement quand c'est arrivé pour nous ça me paraît normal maintenant tourner à des écouteurs dans le métro dans la rue tout on écoute la
musique quand il veut mais à l'époque personne faisait ça aide un coup des gens se sont mis à avoir des casques sur les oreilles
à faire ça et c'était assez ma vie vous allez voir comme il est présente c'est intéressant depuis 18 mois environ au wat en france
des hommes et des dames aussi bien qu'ils ont sur les oreilles un casque
leur permettant d'écouter la musique même dans les bruits de la circulation ce sont des walkman
vous avez sûrement croisé au détour d'une rue
un de ses personnages bizarres coiffé d'un drôle de casse un de ses personnages
bizarres il ne manquait que les antennes pour évoquer une autre planète
Ouais cette phrase elle montre bien qu'elle pourrait c'était
incroyable de voir des gens avec des casse les oreilles c'était j'en veux des gens venus d'un autre monde presque c'était n'importe quand on n'avait
jamais vu ça avant mais beaucoup de gens qui me regardent avec
un scanner une nouvelle génération du 20e siècle
ça les étonne un peu de voir le walkman mais moi je m'en fous éperdument
du mont houy je suis bien c'est principale entre pâques et un peu la même chose aujourd'hui avec tous les jeunes cons et téléphone dans
les marais les gens un peu plus âgé d'une autre génération vont dire c'est quoi ça et sont bizarres ces gens ils sont tout le
temps sur leur écran comme ça et va ces gens là qui ont acheté un walkman quand ils étaient jeunes leurs parents
avaient le même discours avec eux et nous on fera bien entendu
pareil avec nos enfants qu'ils utiliseront une nouvelle technologie qu'on comprend pas trop ces choses à fou comme on reproduit tout le temps
une invention qui enchante surtout les vendeurs 1 millions d'appareils vendus en france depuis un an et demi
son prix entre 800 et 1200 francs putain entre 100 et 200 euros quand même c'était cher
une mode oui mais une mode peut être pas sans conséquences il ne s'agit pas d' éviter aux autres le bruit que l'on peut faire
mais de s'éviter à soit le bruit et la présence des autres Qu'est-ce qui se passe là ?
Pour les psychiatres c'est une nouvelle rupture plus grave que celle des générations
alors ce danseur au walkman,
fait-il un pas en arrière
ou un pas en avant." Il fait un giga pas en avant ! je veux le voir tous les matins sur mon trajet pour le studio Et la
dernière que je trouve incroyable que je vais vous montrer c'est un truc sur les poissons d'avril à l'époque en fait la
télévision française et les médias jouaient vraiment le jeu du poisson d'avril
il se faisait vraiment chez pour monter un vrai canular et les gens y croyaient vraiment pas mal c'est un peu une tradition les gens
les gens généralement étaient offusquées devant le canular parce que le canular c'était souvent
une soi-disante loi qui allait passer et qui allait en gros
réduire les libertés des gens sauf que il ya des canulars qu'ils ont fait à l'époque et ça s'est vraiment passé aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment dans la loi aujourd'hui et c'est super drôle de se dire qu'à l'époque ils ont présenté un truc comme un canular et qu'aujourd'hui c'est
passé. Bon je viens de... je viens juste de ré juste de répéter ce que j'ai dis.... MAIS C'EST SUPER DROLE NAN?
72 le canular c'est l'interdiction de fumer dans les lieux publics ce qui est aujourd'hui en rigueur mais à l'époque c'est inimaginable
une cigarette vous ne pourrez plus le faire en toute liberté dans mon ministre
après consultation naturellement avec le gouvernement et avec le ministre de l'environnement a décidé
la suppression de la licence que constituait la possibilité de fumer dans les lieux publics désormais tous les français devront s'y conformer
croyez vous que cette mesure sera facile à faire appliquer certainement pas chaque ainsi que le français très individualiste
qu'il croit beaucoup à ses droits et peut à ses doigts
mais est ce que notre peuple a toujours détesté notre peuple c'est fou aimons nous soyons fiers de nous
bon alors qu'en pensent les gens là on veut voir les témoignages là ne plus fumer dans les lieux publics c'est
terrible dit nous parce que qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette interdiction de fumer dans les lieux publics
Oui il dit j'ai appris ça ce matin parce qu'à l'époque tout mon lisez les journaux tout le monde d'écouter la radio n'y avait pas
autant de médias que maintenant du coup vraiment les gens lisaient le truc et on était au courant en même temps de
l'interdiction donc le canada il paraissait tellement réel des atteintes à la liberté individuelle et la prime en qu'on
avait les avis sont mitigés quand même ça intéressant alors que caen s'est passé derrière tout le monde
comprenait quoi bon s'est passé beaucoup plus tard attention en quelle année
2006 s'est passé
quarante ans plus tard mais alors déjà à l'époque ya plein de gens qui étaient pour il a fallu quarante ans pour que ça pour
que ça passe c'est fou
Ce que ça peut gêner les légendes dans la rue on arrivait à 9 heures les voitures pourquoi
L'argument vu les voitures tout on a le droit j'adore pourquoi
La minorité fait le choix de faire quelque chose qui nie que sa santé et celle de ceux qui n'ont pas fait ce choix aussi
et qui sont en plus la majorité mais la solution c'est quoi c'est que la majorité se cassent ils sont pas contents
argument d'enfer il gagne tout un des canulars et je vous fous la paix c'est le téléphone dans les
voitures à l'époque n'avait pas de téléphone portable
enfin il y en avait avec..., c'était un énorme truc qu'on tenait,
on tenait le combiné en fait y avait une antenne et ça coûtait la peau du cul c'était inaccessible.
Et là, le canular fait croire que enfin il y a un téléphone
portable qui sera dans les voitures et qui sera hyper accessible. Ce qui est faux.
"Posséder un téléphone dans sa voiture de type portable comme celui ci est un investissement coûteux." Combien ? "Vingt à vingt cinq mille francs l'appareil."
Hein !? Presque 4000 euros le téléphone. "Dès le mois de juin prochain les japonais vont investir le marché européen en important des combinés téléphoniques
pour voitures au prix de 900 francs c'est pour contrer cette invasion que les télécommunications vont proposer aux usagers
un système
imparable à la portée de toutes les bourses. Alors montrez-le nous ce téléphone qui sonne dans les voitures, à quoi il ressemble ?
l'appareil proposé par les
télécommunications il ressemble étrangement à un appareil qu'on branchait soi son prix 250 francs auquel il est relié à l'auto radio sur la bande fm
de l'autre côté
sur la bande fm mais c'est la même prise qu'on utilise chez soi ça se voit les mecs qu'ils faisaient le canular avec les moyens du
bord j'adore bon comment ça marche ditent nous qu'est-ce que vous avez inventé l'antenne radio transmet la fréquence jusqu'au relais
hertziens des télécoms de mesnil esnard lequel renvoie la communication au central téléphonique qui joue son rôle normalement
"En fait les "signals" "part" à un endroit puis "repart" un autre oh c'est technologique
franchement j'y aurait cru direct à l'époque avouez c'est super bien fait et bien écoutez c'est la fin de cette petite
revue de vidéos de l'INA j'ai pas pris les plus connus j'espère que vous les aviez pas vu en tout cas pour ceux qui connaissaient
pas ou ceux qui en avait vu juste deux ou trois je vous invite à aller sur la chaîne youtube je mettrais le lien en description c'est
C'est vraiment très intéressant et je trouve que ça fait réaliser plein de choses il ya vraiment eu des gaps technologiques
énorme une manière de penser aussi qui a beaucoup changé mais pas tant on l'a vu et surtout moi donc
dans ma tête
ça c'était vraiment y'a je sais pas combien de temps je saurais pas comment vous dire j'ai l'impression que c'était il y a cents ans quoi
mais pas du tout en fait il ya vraiment que 35 ans d'écart entre certaines vidéos qu'on a vu et maintenant c'est rien 35 ans
c'est juste que vos parents bah ils avaient notre âge au moment où ça s'est sorti quoi je trouve ça fou comme tout va très
vite comme tout a changé très très vite quoi, regardez maintenant il y' a des ipads des téléphones portables des écrans
4k des jeux vidéo incroyable en 3d qui tournent et regardez il ya seulement 35 ans on était si loin de ça c'est fou !
je vous dis à bientôt à une prochaine vidéo je m'en vais poser plein de questions à mes parents parce que ça me fascine en
ce moment leur époque et je vous dis à bientôt voilà portez vous bien au revoir